Hey youtubers is Charlie! Game of Thrones
finale tonight so I wanted to do a video
all about why was so important that Jon
Snow's mother like the secret be kept
this whole time like why couldn't
someone tell Jon Snow who his mother was
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far we're
going to be using some of the flashbacks
that we've seen on the show in some of
the context from the books just to
explain why it was so important that
nobody could know that Jon Snow
might be the son of Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna Stark and why has the show
waited this long to reveal it to viewers
but mostly I think because the show
likes to set things that like it likes
to give you a reason for you needing to
know something before it gives you the
information Jon Snow being the son of
Rhaegar Targaryen would mean that he has
a claim to the throne so it makes sense
the show wouldn't try to reveal that to
you unless the Kingdom needed a new
leader and we have a leader right now
technically it's Tommen he's not a very
good leader but he's still technically
the king of Westeros so if a new
candidate with a claim to the throne
were to surface it would probably plunge
the kingdom into civil war which is
probably why Ned Stark never told anyone
about Jon Snow's true parentage the
other important thing about this reveal
isn't so much who Jon Snow's parents are
is also changing the way you view
relationships before Robert's rebellion
so a lot of people know about the
tourney of Harrenhal we've seen a couple
moments on the show that have teased
that when Rhaegar Targaryen crown Leon a
stark with blue roses he won the tourney
and crowned her instead of his wife Elia
Martell so it sounds like he may have
been in a loveless marriage and may have
been in love with Lyanna Stark but she
had been promised to Robert Baratheon so
there were a lot of reasons for Robert's
rebellion he's I mean he's credited
because he kind of led the rebellion
he's the one that took the Iron Throne
after it was over but there were a whole
lot of other reasons for Robert's
rebellion but assuming Robert's
rebellion hadn't ended so tragically for
everyone involved Lyanna Stark Rhaegar
Targaryen had survived and they had
lived to raise Jon Snow together you can
imagine socially what a scandal it would
be for the Kingdom
if Rhaegar were to have a very public
bastard how Robert might have reacted he
still might have gone on a tear so I
think the biggest most obvious reason
for keeping Jon Snow's true parentage
secret this whole time was one to
prevent another Civil War he
would have been utter chaos in the
kingdom you have to remember that even
though Robert won the rebellion there's
probably still a lot of Targaryen
sympathizers out there that's what Varys
is doing right now that's why he left
marine to go back to Westeros he's
looking for people that are sympathetic
to Daenerys he's trying to find
Targaryen sympathizers so people like
Sam Wells father who fought for the Mad
King during Robert's rebellion probably
would love to see another Targaryen on
the throne so if Jon Snow slashed
Targaryen were to surface a lot of
people would be like we hate Robert
Baratheon we hate this administration we
hate Joffrey we hate the Lannisters we
want a true Targaryen on the throne so
already that's a huge problem that
you're trying to decide step the other
problem is that Robert wins the
rebellion he gains the power in the
support of half the kingdom so the other
half of the kingdom would hate the idea
of Jon Snow being a Targaryen so they'd
be out for his head like Robert would
probably try to smash Jon Snow's head
with his Warhammer because personally he
would remind him of this like perceived
betrayal of Lyanna Stark even though
Lyanna stark never really loved Robert
Baratheon she was betrothed to him but
you can see how like Cersei was
betrothed to Robert did not love him
people in this context noble born people
get married off all the time Sansa had
to get married to Ramsay did not want to
do that at all so that was kind of the
situation with Lyanna stark and Robert
Baratheon so you have a lot of political
reasons for keeping Jon Snow secret then
you have a lot of personal reasons too
we don't want Robert to roll himself off
the throne pick up his war hammer and
come charging after Jon Snow so the
other big question that you're all
asking is why wouldn't Ned Stark tell
Jon Snow though Jon Snow might be able
to keep a secret wouldn't you want
someone to know who their mother is well
that probably goes back to the idea of
Ned Stark being honorable to a fault he
wanted to keep his sister secret as much
as possible he never even mentioned Jon
Snow he never even talked about the
circumstances around how he was born to
Catelyn Stark he just showed up with Jon
Snow back at Winterfell after Robert's
rebellion and Catelyn just said he never
talked about it so she just assumed that
Jon Snow was his bastard but as of
season 1 when Jon Snow was getting ready
to go to the wall like when they parted
ways for the last time he did say the
next time we meet we'll talk about your
mother so he had intended to tell him
who his mother was eventually so it's
not like Ned Stark wanted to take the
secret with him to his grave and there
are other people in the books
were there like Howland Reed would have
also known about baby John Stehr so what
a coincidence that he's been missing
this whole time on the TV show and in
the books but here's my big question for
you why do you think that Ned Stark did
not tell Jon Snow who his mother was
before he went to the wall do you think
that he was just being honorable to a
fault or he was just being lazy about
like I'll just I'll tell you next time
we meet like I'll totally come visit you
up at the wall but then he got caught up
with all the intrigue that was going on
at King's Landing ended up losing his
head so that was the end of that but the
next big question is is how is Jon Snow
going to learn about this brain is very
clearly learning about this in
flashbacks but he'll have to meet with
Jon Snow and tell him himself somewhere
communicate with him Hey look your
mother this is your but like he'll have
to give him that vision wouldn't that be
crazy
showing Jon Snow a psychic videotape of
his birth
that would be super meta but it'll
probably be somewhat simpler and we the
audience will probably know for a while
before Jon Snow himself learns who his
mother is like we'll see the flashback
you know we'll all be cheering in the
background but Jon Snow himself in the
context of the story won't be saying
like bran will then have to go tell him
what he's learned so get hyped for the
finale tonight I'll be doing all kinds
of bonus videos next week too we have to
talk about the aftermath in season seven
predictions so quick reminder there is a
new round of the giveaway that's going
on right now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card in all announce the winner
when I post my Q&A video which will be
sometime in the middle of next week
so finale tonight if you have a game of
Thrones t-shirt where tonight like I'm
wearing my stark shirt again tonight so
hell yeah and I will be live-tweeting
tonight there's a link down in the
description for my Twitter account I'll
try to be as non-spoilery as possible it
is going to be a lot of fun so while you
guys wait for my finale video tonight
you can click here to learn all about
bastards on Game of Thrones and you can
click here for my episode 9 video from
last week thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight!